no creas que todas las ecuaciones son
perfectas y que se parecen a esta eso
sería genial porque las ecuaciones donde
hay números en lugar de la a b y c se
pueden resolver sin ningún problema
mediante productos notables como en este
caso que tenemos un trinomio cuadrado
perfecto con 4x cuadrada más 20 x más 25
igual a cero así que lo factor izamos
como un binomio al cuadrado y queda como
2 x + 5 al cuadrado o con la fórmula
general para ecuaciones de segundo grado
x igual a menos de más menos raíz
cuadrada debe al cuadrado menos 4 a
porsche todo entre 2 a si sustituimos
los valores de a b y c para a sería 4
porque corresponde a la equis cuadrada
para ver el 20 de la equis lineal y para
hacer el 25 del término independiente de
esta manera la fórmula general quedaría
así x igual a menos 20 más menos raíz
cuadrada de 20 al cuadrado menos 4 por 4
x 25 todo entre 2 x 4
resolviendo los factores dentro de la
raíz tenemos 400 menos 400 y en el
divisor nos queda 8 al restar 400 menos
400 tenemos raíz de 0 así que se elimina
y quedaría menos 20 entre 8 que es igual
a menos 5 medios esto es lo ideal pero
no siempre encontramos ecuaciones que
tengan un valor para a otro para b y
otro para hacer la a siempre la vamos a
tener porque si su valor fuera cero no
habría x al cuadrado y por lo tanto
nuestra ecuación no sería cuadrática lo
que sí es posible es no contar con el
término que corresponde a b x
o que no haya valor independiente en ce
así que es importante saber cómo
resolver este tipo de ecuaciones si el
término que falta es b como en 3 x
cuadrada menos 5 igual a 0 lo que
haríamos sería sustituir a como 3 la b
tendrá valor de 0 y la se valdrá menos 5
en la fórmula general de ecuaciones
cuadráticas quedaría de la siguiente
manera x es igual a menos 0 + menos raíz
cuadrada de 0 al cuadrado menos 4 x 3 x
menos 5 todo entre 2 x 3
así que no hay problema simplificar
tenemos dentro de la raíz 0 más 60 y el
divisor 16
el 0 fuera de la raíz lo omitimos y solo
nos quedamos con raíz de 60 entre 6
recuerda que colocamos el más menos
antes de la raíz porque las ecuaciones
cuadráticas tienen dos resultados el que
se obtiene con la raíz positiva y otro
con la raíz negativa si al resolver con
la fórmula nos encontramos con algún
número imaginario o una indeterminación
entonces nuestra ecuación no tiene
solución sólo hay que identificar qué
valor debe o si no tenemos para colocar
un cero en su lugar ahora ya sabes cómo
solucionar ecuaciones cuadráticas sin
importar que esté incompletas o no